sing in the back hey I ready Randy is
back on TV I just feel like everything
happens when it's supposed to and this
is this is the moment this is the
perfect time it's been 20 years since
the singer / actress made her debut on
the small screen in Moishe the show ran
for six seasons and left a lasting
impression on its star Brandi tells
ETonline I think for young black girls
to grow up through her journey and
through her eyes and to see a young
black girl with braids in her hair it
leaves the legacy of possibility now the
36 year old is ready to test her comedy
chops again a skill she grew into I'm a
lot more comfortable with music because
singing can come natural it comes
natural acting I have to focus like
really really focused two decades later
Brandi says she still gets nervous the
nerves are worse now she says I was
fearless as a kid I have adult nerves
now and basically they don't go away but
I'm blessing up to not allow them to
[ __ ] me and I'm just inspired all
over again in my life so
you